the steps taken by the chancellor today
are we all going to be poorer will mean
economic pain is this austerity 2.0 for
almost all of us the weather befitting
the mood
chancellor who knows he's facing a storm
says he entered the commons but the
the anything but cheery the country now
officially in recession and people set
to feel it today we deliver a plan to
tackle the cost of living crisis and
rebuild our economy but it means taking
difficult decisions
anyone who says there are easy answers
is not being straight with the British
people this Chancellor been straight
about the need to restore public
finances and calm the markets with a 55
billion package of tax Rises and
spending cuts we want low taxes and
sound money that conservatives know
sound money has to come first so tax
Rises for the richest the first
difficult decision I take on tax is to
reduce the Threshold at which the 45p
rate becomes payable from 150 000 pounds
to 125
140 pounds and freeze in tax thresholds
across the board to raise revenue I'm
maintaining at current levels the income
tax personal allowance higher rate
threshold main National Insurance
thresholds and the inheritance tax
thresholds for a further two years the
country's tax burden set to be the
highest since the second World War 25
billion in tax rises even more in
spending cuts forcing departments to
make efficiencies we do have to take
difficult decisions on public finances
so we're going to grow public spending
but we're going to grow it more slowly
than the growth in the economy windfall
taxes too for energy companies as the
Tory Chancellor took on labor policy
I've decided that from January the 1st
until March 28 we will increase the
energy profits Levy from 25 to 35
percent
the cabinet in agreement but this fiscal
statement the opposite of the tax cut in
Bonanza promised by Liz truss one past
policy though revived but not as
generous
from April we'll continue the energy
price guarantee for a further 12 months
at a higher level of 3 000 pounds per
year for the average household
any other but very few winners here
are schools and Health Service the
exceptions both of their budgets
increasing this is a balanced plan for
stability a plan for growth and a plan
for public services and I commend this
statement of the house foreign
the chancellor and those at his side
pleased with the performance but the
other side of this chamber unconvinced
in is the result of 12 weeks of
conservative chaos but also 12 years of
conservative economic failure
growth dismal investment down wages
squeezed Public Services crumbling
and some on the Tory bench is not happy
either well my brother and friend agree
with me that raising taxes risks stiping
the growth and productivity that he and
I both want can we move more quickly
than he's announced today towards
delivering a lower tax economy but the
Autumn statement promises anything but
Britain's now facing its highest levels
of Taxation since the second world war
as the chancellor turns trussonomics and
all its tax cuts on its head in a bid to
restore Britain's economic credibility
but it brings with it economic pain
households are now facing the steepest
fall in living standards in over six
decades it's going to be very Grim for
the government but the next couple of
years are going to be even Grimmer for
all of us
this a government and a Chancellor Keen
to learn the lessons of their
predecessors is that all right but while
some like this school in South London
might feel alright the majority will not
a long recession looming and living
standards set to fall this is going to
hurt bathroom B Sky News Westminster
right okay